the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ] ever
the wait is over
[Music]
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
when you get knocked down
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
i've been in the drawer but i know
enough
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough but you're still blowing people up
as if life's not hard enough this guy's
one badass dude
[Music]
oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat
snake venomous
[Applause]
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in mma i told aaron it was a lightweight
that's not a lie what are you guys
talking about
[Music]
we're in this together pops what's the
worst that could happen
[Music]
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
[Music]
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
there ain't a bunch of nasa scientists
right now can i get a cold thing
[Music]
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie i made another one
it's gotta be over dude i think we're
all the way finished we're through
stick a fork in it
[Music]
[Music]